finally made it Dane the boy Dame is
here what up man I made it people who
don't know uh what do you do because I
feel like you DJ you a r and you're
putting out records what do you got a
record label yeah man my employment
title is I'm the I'm the head a r over
at CMG with Gotti right
um
for my own stuff man I got my own label
play too much and uh I'm an artist over
at Dev gym so
how did you start off in the bay because
you obviously have roots in the bay and
from what I understand the Yo Gotti [ __ ]
popped off because you put them on the
pillow [ __ ] right yeah yeah that was my
first a r record
um May I start off as an intern like
with Chewie Gomez shout out to Chewie
the legend that's my Legend like my my
big homie Chewie and then from being at
the station running around with Vine in
my emotion
um then they taught they forced me how
to DJ you know what I'm saying I used to
just kind of play around on people's
stuff after the shows my emotion was
like bro don't disrespect our culture
like that like yeah go practice how to
blend and match the vpms and stuff like
that so
just getting into that and I started
picking out local records that end up
becoming something in the bay so I guess
they start believing in my musical
Talent which records uh Rod I can't
stand you the r b record
um and I was picking a bunch of B-side
records like Plies I'm really from the
hood uh just that type of stuff to where
Vining them was like
he kind of know what he talking about
they ain't give me the food you know
what I'm saying and uh
I realize radio man them dudes it's like
it's only four spots you know four times
spots yeah so I knew and they was making
a lot of money I knew them dudes wasn't
about to quit or retire no time soon so
I had to make a transition and uh
I was also like the little go get it
dude at the station like go get some
coffee no no no no other girl get like
Street go get it like we need some
[ __ ] we need some weeds yeah we
needed something to hold us down that
type of stuff so I was building that
relationship with a bunch of the artists
and um Gotti was one of the artists that
I went to build the relationship with
right um I don't know he took a like and
beat memes his cousin took a liking it
to me they invited me to the studio
radio was already like dying out for me
right and uh [ __ ] I was in Oakland they
hit me up send me the address but the uh
the studios in Burbank you know
everybody think California is close it's
crazy yeah yeah so I'm like [ __ ] it I
just got in the car and drove out here
then I went to the studio I had to go
walk through a bunch of Memphis [ __ ]
and you know they like play some beats
and that's when the mustard was cracking
right
um I'm Different was that all right
everybody wanted one of them yeah yeah
and uh
so I started playing a bunch of Beats
but bro it was like he kind of was like
he wasn't feeling them and he's like man
you got one more record and then I
caught pilo I'm like please send me a
Beat and I end up being act right
um
we it's a little joke though I think he
was kind of dissing this though still
because he said I'm going going back to
the bay that's a piece of Mac Dre I
think he was sending me back to the Bay
like you catching else like sending us
back to the bank but he said it in the
whole room was like you know what I'm
saying like a and R's in there I even
know where the a r was back then
um they all went crazy for it